hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from round six that took place
yesterday in the magnus crossing
invitational uh the second the day of
the preliminaries it's wesley saw versus
levin arnon
and it's uh quite a beauty this is uh
well uh maybe a miniature i don't know
if you guys consider
uh 30 35 must be a miniature but in
today's
day and age i do think 35 moves can be
considered a miniature
so uh without further ado let's check it
out as it's uh
it's really really an amazing game uh
hence the the paul morphe quote above
the board
uh so wesley with the white pieces uh
opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 by eleven uh we
have c4
sorry about that uh and e6
uh so preparing to develop the light
square bishop and inviting wesley to
to go for the nimzo we have knight to c3
and the bishop to b4
11 goes for the nimzo indian defense and
now the most popular
here is e3 and queen to c2 and uh we
have the traditional line
with uh queen to c2 or the classical
variation whatever it's called
uh we have castles uh by eleven uh and
now
knight to f3 just continuing development
black will of course
uh try to strike in the center with d5
he's going to play b6
if he encountered the light square
bishop uh and so on gradually develop
pieces not with d5 striking in the
center
and now bishop to g5 pinning the knight
here
and uh 11 immediately goes after the
bishop we have h6
uh bishop to h4 and now d captures on c4
uh we have e4 grabbing more space in the
center
and now it seems like uh black could put
more pressure on this spawn
or and you don't want to meet e5 here so
uh
g5 the the most common move here is c5
but 11 goes uh
into the most aggressive variation with
the g5
so okay bishop has to move we have
bishop to g3 and
now b5 defending that pawn here uh on c4
and if you can do this then it's uh then
it's great for you if you can
then it's not going to be so great and
here there is one game where a4 was
played trying to challenge this
uh set up uh black created on the queen
side but here we have
e5 instead and it is uh uh
already as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game
so you're kicking away the knight you're
preparing to shift the queen to e4 the
rook on a8 is undefended so there are a
lot of very
uh very nice ideas here in the position
so here knight to h five by eleven
and the queen to e4 remaneuvering the
queen with an attack on the rook so
queen to d5 uh the knight of course
cannot capture it's pinned by the bishop
here
and the wesley declines the trade again
moving the queen with tempo as the
knight is undefended so
knights the g7 uh and now bishop to e2
preparing the castle and continue
development
and here uh well you could do a lot of
things 11 continues in the most
aggressive way possible and that is with
f5 and f5 really really is an impressive
move because it seems like the queen has
almost no squares and if you go to h3
then just g4 will come with a double
attack on the queen and the knight
uh and in fact it um
uh it's uh well it's uh it's not the the
greatest of moves because uh
uh well if you go e captures on f6 with
check then black has this very
very strong e5 move attacking the white
queen and
it's going to be extremely extremely
hard to play this black can't play this
and white could survive but it's
very unclear for example you could try
knight the d2
now the knight is threatening to capture
the black queen but now you just play
bishop captures on c3
and white's queen is still hanging now
you're gonna go bishop to f3 attack the
black queen
now bishop captures on d2 with check
king captures and now you're gonna move
the queen
again uh i mean still attacking the
white queen
and only after the queen moves and now
you're gonna win this pawn
rook captures an f6 and you don't really
care about anything here if queen
captures on e8 you're just gonna play
queen to b
for check you're gonna play c3 and it's
uh it's a very
well ugly looking position to play with
white so uh after f5 this is what levin
had in mind all the tactics go in his
favor but wesley finds the absolute
strongest move and that is queen to h3
he even invites levin to
go for g4 and the double attack here
which he does
we have g4 uh and the queen captures on
h6 here we have g
captures on f3 grabbing that piece and
bishop capture so now attacking the
queen the rook is still on a8
we have queen captures on d4 and now
going after the rook would be a bit
too dangerous if bishop captures an a8
then we get bishop captures on c3 with
check and again you have problems
captures captures with check
uh the rook is under attack so you have
to block with king to e2 now the rooks
are defending each other but now f4
uh cutting off the queen's uh uh reach
to the to
to go back to help out with the defense
and there's just uh
not all that much white can do here it's
just a very
ugly position to play so instead after
queen captures on d4
wesley just castles and he says i'm now
ready to continue my attack
uh the rook is still under attack so c6
11 defends it and now
rook a to d1 pushing back the black
queen
queen back to b6 and now comes knight
to e4 and this knight the e4 is the
uh is the is definitely the move to uh
to
discuss uh because here bishop to h4 uh
seems to be just a game over for black
you're threatening a bishop to f6 and
that's just it
uh you could continue with something
like knight d7 to take away the f6
square from the bishop but you can just
eliminate the knight it's not a problem
bishop captures now bishop f6
threatening checkmate and if rook to f7
defending
only then do you bring the knight in
with knight to e4 but now it's a little
bit different because if
of course you're coming to g5 uh but if
the pawn is captured bishop captures
then you gain access to the h7 square
and there isn't all that much uh
uh you can do here check and mate is
coming so you could try to prolong with
something like this
but just brush up the h7 check king f7
captures with check and now it doesn't
matter you can go to e8 bishop to g6
will be checkmate
so uh it's a very very tough position to
spot all the correct moves but
uh wesley instead of going for this
starts with a knight to e4 but now it's
a little bit different
uh because he allows 11 one uh one small
possibility of a defense uh because
11 accepts now the knight with f
captures on e4
bishop captures and now rook to f5 so he
uh grabbed some material but now he
wants to give back some material in
order to survive the attack
uh wesley accepts this we have bishop
captures on f5
uh e captures an f5 and now e6 trying to
get to that e7 square then ideas like
rook to d8 become possible the bishop
cannot come to e5
and a lot of attacking potential here so
here bishop back to f8
now ready to move the knight with some
with some nice discoveries also
it's a very good defender to the knight
and bishop to e5 now
now already you have some plans of maybe
pushing uh bishop captures queen
captures with
checkmate uh so here c5 is played now if
the pawn is pushed uh
queen captures queen can be played but
this is where you guys come in uh feel
free to pause the video and
win this game for wesley in the coolest
possible way uh well i give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh
doing exactly what i told you you can't
do and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
uh it's bishop captures and g7
bishop captures and now is e7 you offer
the queen
black and capture it with the queen and
the the bishop but it's only a temporary
queen sacrifice
uh because if the queen is accepted then
just e8 queen
and there's not all that much you can do
king to h7 you're going to play queen
captures on c8
and yes black does have a knight and a
bishop for a rook but there's no way to
develop and it's just a very ugly
position
those rooks are now coming into the game
and it's going to be very scary for
black
this completely winning for white
capturing with the bishop uh doesn't
really do
change anything because if bishop
captures you still just to bring a queen
into the game
and after something like this you still
capture the bishop and again not much
not much different the rooks are coming
into the game and that's it
so here where eleven tried the absolute
best way to defend he tried bishop to d7
uh now he guards the queening square and
hopefully he can develop the knight next
if he can develop the knight then he
should be able to survive
but wesley spots the only winning idea
here
and that is queen to h5 now guarding the
queening square
and now it doesn't matter you can't
really develop the knight you can't do
anything if the knight moves the bishop
is no longer defended so
obviously just winning for white so
queen to c6 was played now
guarding the e8 square twice but now
rook after e1
again preparing to push the pawn bishop
to e8 stopping this while attacking the
queen
and now rook to d8 pinning the bishop
so here knight to a six by eleven now uh
preparing to
trade here uh but again it it it doesn't
help because here
wesley goes in with rook to e6 just
removing
the defender uh the defender of the e8
square and uh what do you do here well
if you go
after the rook then just rook captures
any eight with check and that's it
rook captures queen captures with the
check and it doesn't matter what you do
king h7
queen h5 check king to g8 and now e8
queen and that's it
black has to start giving up material
with either queen captures uh and then
queen captures your down a queen or if
the bishop blocks then you can just
either checkmate the
the black king or just win the queen you
can do whatever you want here
so after rook the e6 we have queen to d7
again eleven uses uh tricks very well
now if rook captures the queen
bishop can also capture the queen but
wesley just
grabs a free rook so rook captures an a8
again
this is not possible because you just
capture and this is still pin so you
cannot go after the queen
so knight the c7 with a double attack on
the rooks but now wesley just goes back
rook to d8 attacks the queen again the
idea is the same
uh if you if you go for queen captures
on e6 doesn't really matter just rook
captures any eight and we get the exact
same pattern knight captures queen
captures with
check you're gonna play check and then
again queen the pawn
so instead after rook to d8 we have
knight
captures on e6 grabbing that rook but
now rook captures on e8 again you have
to be careful if you grab the queen
bishop captures on h5 again becomes
possible
so just rook captures an e8 this is what
we came here to do
and now again you don't really have a
good move knight to f8 was played
but here just a rook captures on f8 and
it was in this position on move 33
uh that uh lebanon resigned the game and
uh a brilliant brilliant victory for
wesley so
as he yet again proves that he is the
absolute master of uh of uh you know
attacking in weird positions he's the
uh world fisher random champion and it's
just uh amazing how he always creates
such masterpieces uh so i hear you
resign because you either capture
which uh doesn't end well if capture is
just queen g6 check
you either move the king away or for
example the bishop blocks and then you
just bring the queen into the game
that's it captures captures you will be
up a full queen
or if after this uh you decide to move
the king uh that's even worse of course
um uh not not much to be done there if
king dha just the captures on f8 with
checkmate you can bring the queen or the
rook into the game uh sure after will
capture snf8 levin resigned and
wesley with this monstrosity of a game
uh against against the full point so
really really impressive stuff
and uh i said we were gonna check out
the standings at some point and we
didn't so here are the standings let me
just
enlarge this a little bit uh there so
you can see uh anish giri
uh leading the tournament with eight
points out of ten followed by magnus
carlsen with seven and a half out of ten
as you know gary
defeated magnus in this tournament i
still haven't shown this game but i
might as it could be
a very important game uh for the
standings i'm sure you guys would enjoy
it
uh but uh you know this is a masterpiece
so we have to
you know uh you know the better the
moves the the more we show
so uh followed by wesley so and hikaru
nakamura with six and a half out of ten
and then we have uh ferruja and maxine
vashilagra with six out of them uh
lebanon
and daniel dubo with five out of ten uh
then we have
uh sorry with five uh also sergey
karakin yani pom nishin timura jabba
with four and a half out of ten
with four mamadaram and grandelus and
with three we have one forest
uh which two and a half david anton
giharo and alan pishot
uh with two uh out of ten uh the the
wild card
uh so yeah that's the game and those
were the standings hope you guys enjoyed
that uh i would like to thank
bonclouches.com
henry almei scott melissa locasterokaris
and the
dale lear for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of the
tournament checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh so thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day